ROGER MARTINEZ: Hi.
Roger here from Google Cloud.
And in this video, we'll
have a look at Pay Later
and its relation
to Open Banking,
a sample implementation
of the API,
and the wider picture of
consuming and publishing APIs.
Open Banking is a system of
allowing access and control
of consumer banking
and financial accounts
through third
party applications.
It encourages interoperability
between banks and consumers
by making available the
bank's core services,
and accelerating their
digital transformation.
First, we'll show you
a common use case,
and then we'll
unpack it for you.
We'll start with the
end-user experience.
An API consumer, in
this case a merchant
in the e-commerce industry
offering last-minute Chromebook
deals, develops a
new app experience
using Google Assistant.
Let's have a look.
Talk to Pixelbook Deals Store.
SPEAKER 2: Hi.
Welcome to the
Pixelbook Deals Store.
What can I do for you?
ROGER MARTINEZ: Are there
any special offerings?
SPEAKER 2: Here you go.
You've selected Pixelbook
Go, 16 gigabytes RAM,
costing 854 pounds.
Would you like to
pay now or pay later?
ROGER MARTINEZ: Pay later.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
Now choose the bank you're with.
After login to your bank, I need
to link your Pixelbook Deals
Store account to Google.
Is that OK?
ROGER MARTINEZ: Yes.
When your account
was linked to Google,
the app can customize
your experience
based on your identity.
Financial data or authentication
data cannot be collected via
the conversational interface.
So we're now shown the terms
and conditions for Pay Later,
and there's a link to
review those conditions.
Simply click on
it and then return
to the deal page when ready.
Here's a sample reference to
the terms and conditions page.
Whenever we're ready, we can
go back to the main screen
and say, all good.
We now see some of the
loan offers to Pay Later.
We can scroll up and
still reference the terms
and conditions if we want to.
Once we're ready, we'll
select the desired loan.
SPEAKER 2: OK that's it.
Pixelbook Go, 16 gigabytes
RAM is now yours.
We'll take it from there and
send you a confirmation email
across shortly.
Speak soon.
Bye.
ROGER MARTINEZ: Until
now, we've looked
at this from the
perspective of a merchant
leveraging the bank's Pay Later
APIs to improve the checkout
experience.
But how do we get access
in the first place?
Stepping back to look
at the wider picture,
there are more actors involved
to get it all working.
First, the bank wants
to share a service.
In this case, the Pay Later
API, but still maintain
some restrictions, such
as applying a call limit.
Second, it's the merchant who is
asking for access to those APIs
in order to build better apps.
Third, it's API product managers
within the organization who
treat APIs as products,
and therefore are
looking at publishing
easy onboarding content
and getting an overview
of the usage statistics.
Now we'll have a look at how a
developer can find those APIs.
In this case, as an
API consumer again.
Here's a sample developer
portal of the bank,
which allows anyone to browse
through the API catalog.
Here we are already logged
in as an app developer
of a partnering organization,
in this case, the merchant.
And the first thing a
developer typically does
is build a developer
application.
We already have here the
Deal Finder Assistant,
previously created.
Upon approval of the bank,
you receive credentials.
Namely an API key and secret
to access this Pay Later API.
Very often, developers
want to test this API
and want to see what
the response is.
Or how to embed it
in the application.
We can go into the Pay
Later API specification,
and we can see all the
different paths and operations.
Under Loan, Payment, and Refund,
we can send a test request.
For that, first of all,
we have to authorize.
We select the app from before
and authorize that the API
key credentials be stored.
Now we can enter some consumer
ID and some payment resource
identification, and
execute the call.
This will return a payload, and
give a developer an overview
of how the API works.
As you can see, Apigee helps
accelerate the publishing
of APIs, making them
ready for consumption
while keeping an eye on
where they're being used.
All in all, this shows what's
possible beyond Open Banking.
Namely, the opportunity to build
new customer channels with more
control over the data,
developers, and partners
to create a
connected experience.
This enhances interoperability
between traditional banking
data with an API ecosystem.
Thanks for listening
in, and feel
free to read more about
Open Banking solution
and what Apigee provides for
APIs in financial services
at the link listed in
the description below.